you all can stick your champagne flutes
up your rose smelling candy taste and
Snow White [__] it [__] and by the
end of the first week of shooting I came
home
and I said to my husband like this is
the hardest I've ever worked like this
is something else and Damien like my
favorite thing about him amongst many is
that he expects so much when he was an
actor we did our first take and I gave
it a lot like I go big on the first take
no I know I go big on first take until
he comes up to me twirling his hair as
he does you know
which means that you haven't given him
what he needs yet so he came up and he's
like
um yeah that was great it was great uh
just need way more
than
more than way more than that wait and I
was like holy [__] I don't know if I had
more